never ruin an apology with an excuse
whatever is begun in anger
ends in shame
by that thou Hast no need of
and air long Thou shalt cell thy
necessities
if a man empties his purse into his head
no one can take it from him
love your enemies
for they tell you your faults
there are three Faithful Friends an old
wife an old dog
and ready money
by failing to prepare
you are preparing to fail
you may delay
but time will not
if you would know the value of money
go and try to borrow some
beware of little expenses a small leak
will sink a great ship
laziness travels so slowly
that poverty soon overtakes him
an investment in knowledge pays the best
interest
he that lies down with dogs
shall rise up with fleas
he that displays too often his wife and
his wallet
is in danger of having both of them
borrowed
fatigue is the best pillow
they who can give up essential Liberty
to obtain little temporary safety
deserve neither Liberty nor safety
[Music]
he that can have patience
can have what he will
it is the first responsibility of every
citizen to question authority
[Music]
those things that hurt instruct
having been poor is no shame
but being ashamed of it is
time is money
I didn't fail the test
I just found 100 ways to do it wrong
well done is better than well said
many people die at 25 and aren't buried
until they are 75.
life's biggest tragedy is that we get
old too soon and wise too late
one today is worth two tomorrows
rather go to bed without dinner than to
rise in debt
at 20 years of age the will rains
at 30 the wit and at 40 the judgment
never leave till tomorrow that which you
can do today
to succeed
jump as quickly at opportunities as you
do at conclusions
lost time is never found again
where there is marriage without love
There Will Be Love without marriage
haste makes waste
three may keep a secret if two of them
are dead
Dost thou love life
then do not squander time
for that's the stuff
life is made of
educate your children to self-control
to the habit of holding possession and
Prejudice and evil Tendencies subject to
an upright and reasoning will
and you will have done much to abolish
misery from their future
and crimes from society
[Music]
keep your eyes wide open before marriage
half shut afterwards
we do not stop playing because we grow
old
we grow old because we stop playing
work as if you were to live a thousand
years
play as if you were to die tomorrow
contentment
makes poor men rich
discontent makes rich men poor
you will find the key to success under
the alarm clock
a penny saved is a penny earned
fear not death for the sooner we die the
longer we shall be immortal
be at war with your vices at peace with
your neighbors
and let every New Year find you a better
man
be slow in choosing a friend
slower in changing
when you are finished changing
you're finished
when you're testing to see how deep
water is never use two feet
an ounce of prevention is worth a pound
of cure
happiness depends more on the inward
disposition of Mind than on outward
circumstances
be civil to all
sociable to many
familiar with few
friend who won
enemy to none
if a man could have half of his wishes
he would double his troubles
speak ill of no man but speak all the
good you know of everybody
to find out a girl's faults
praise her to her girlfriends
A House Is Not a Home unless it contains
food and fire for the mind is well as
the body
security without Liberty is called
prison
instead of cursing the darkness
light a candle
if all printers were determined not to
print anything till they were sure it
would offend nobody
there would be very little printed
never confuse motion with action
early to bed and early to rise in old
age makes a man healthy wealthy and wise
do not trust your money to a person who
likes to count other people's money
the woman who wants the most sex is the
one who often yearns for deeper sense of
intimacy
yet May struggle to find it through
physical means alone
is proof that God loves us and wants us
to be happy
the heart of a fool is in his mouth
the mouth of a wise man is in his heart
there was never a bad peace or a good
War
we must all hang together or assuredly
we shall all hang separately
a slip of the foot you may soon recover
but a slip of the tongue you may never
get over